two biggest categories that i see is
people that don't know where to start
and they just look for
a business to run and i think when you
do that that's where you that's where
you screw up and you end up in the
second category where you're running a
business that's not that profitable
you're not earning significantly more
than what you did before working in the
corporate world and you're exposed to
considerable risk everything that i've
put in my course on the school of
entrepreneurship which is a mindset
course by the way
i'm not giving you do a b c d e to make
a a profitable business what i'm doing
is i'm giving you everything that i've
learned over the years
everything that i've got from my mentors
everything that i've got with guys that
i've mentored everything that i've got
from communities that i've been a part
of organizations learning events all
that stuff
it's been sanitized and essentially
distilled down to about four hours of um
content
and
it essentially tells you what the cheat
codes are to running a business if you
want an elf business if you want
something that's easy-looking fun
because otherwise i mean
i hate it when guys
leave a decent paying job
and they go and start up a business and
then two three years later after they've
spent all the money on it they've
you know like they've uh
barred against the house and all they
really have is a hobby or something
that's not profitable or something
that's not scalable or they're still
trading time for money that's another
big mistake is
you know
um it doesn't matter if you're trading
200
for an hour's work or two thousand
dollars for an hour's work
it's not a scalable system yeah you're
gonna make more you're gonna earn more
if you're building two thousand dollars
an hour but it's still not a scalable
system you need a system ideally like
with an elf business that's highly
profitable is essentially one where you
can earn money while you sleep okay you
can earn money while
you're on vacation you can earn money
while you're sitting in a restaurant
with family having a nice meal
you know enjoying time together sort of
thing that's what's ideal right
and again you know in the course i talk
about all the ways you know you can do
that
um let me just quickly take a quick look
here at the chat here i see you guys are
chatting up the storm amongst yourselves
thanks for the super sticker there
enrique
i will be dropping the q a link guys
um
probably in about 10 or 15 minutes just
a few more things that i want to cover
so if you have questions i will be
taking some calls
in um
and grab the uh shared screen here
yeah thanks for that chris so
chris is part of the part of my
community he got the um
you got the early version of the course
a few weeks ago
a fantastic course finished it this
morning while showering for the day it's
it's not that long i hate stuff that
like rambles on and uses filler words
that's unnecessarily
i just get right to it i just cut right
to the point and i get right to it let
me show you the module so you have an
idea of what you're dealing with and
again guys if you want it the
course is pinned in the live chat right
now it just says learn more about the
course and purchase there i'm going to
show you the um
uh the landing page when you click
through and walk you through the modules
so
if you click through that link this is
where you'll get let me just spread this
out a little bit
um
so here's all the modules here that i've
put in this uh teachable
there's three modules um dealing with
mindset i
actually initially recorded this in one
fell swoop but i had to break it into
three parts because they wouldn't let me
upload it as long form there's like a
basically a 30 minute limit
on
modules but there's three mindset
modules
there's another one on taxes legal
matters and insurance and by the way
guys this is all stuff that you spec
explicitly asked me for about two and a
half months ago when i was putting on
the putting the final touches on this
you guys said to me
you know i'm interested in the course i
want in but i want to make sure that i
understand you know the flow of these
components
and while taxes legal matters and
insurance will vary from country to
country from an overview you know i fly
you up to about 20 000 feet and i talk
about
when it's important to consider things
like your tax obligations how to handle
legal matters when they come your way um
when and why you need insurance like one
of the key things to deal with with
legal matters you know as an aside if
you're an entrepreneur if you're an
inspire aspiring
entrepreneur explain it in more detail
in this module but
you're going to get people that are
going to send you [ __ ] and they're going
to try to change and modify your
behavior for the most part
four to five times and i learned this
from a partner of mine that i'm still
running a business with that happens to
be a lawyer but he sees themselves you
know as an entrepreneur first when you
get a notice that's not registered in
court with a plaintiff's claim
explicitly stating what damages were
suffered and why they're suing you it's
just a letter that says i want you to
change this behavior change this take
this do that take this down whatever you
can just run it through the shredder or
you can wipe it with your ass like
toilet paper this is essentially what a
lawyer told me this is a game that these
guys play back and forth to rack up
billable hours and you can avoid all
that avoid the headache and avoid the
stress because truthfully at the end of
the day
if they're just sending you a notice in
the mail that says we want you to change
your behavior but they haven't spent the
time and money to create the actual
plaintiff's claim register in court you
know go down and pay the filing fee and
all that sort of stuff and then properly
serve it to you with a process server
they're not serious about what they're
trying to do they're just trying to like
egg you on and trying to goose you right
so you can save a lot of time and money
doing that and i found that
it's pretty accurate because
i mean
i ran tdf for almost uh
17 18 years i mean it was going up on
20 years and
every year or two you'd get a notice for
some [ __ ] and honestly like after i
had that conversation with my partner i
saved myself so much time and money
you know for the most part it's just a
ploy to waste your time and it just goes
away um ideal types of businesses to run
so i've got a module on that that covers
that in specific detail one of the big
mistakes that i see guys make today is
they want to be an entrepreneur they
want to run a business they think they
have a good idea or even if they don't
have an idea they kind of like
pick up on others
um let me just switch this over here i
feel like this doesn't need to be that
big you know they kind of pick up on
other guys
modules you'll see things on
social media facebook instagram
you know stuff like that where there's a
guy standing in front of a lambo and
he's like i'm 22 years old and i retired
and i make um 50 000 a day in my sleep
doing amazon fba
a
[ __ ]
it's not it it's not like you know you
can just buy a course
and do a b c d and then replicate a
amazon fba business you know for example
and i'm not picking on amazon but that's
the one that i you know happen to see
the most but
one of the things i talk about
extensively throughout my course is
physical products suck
they create extra layers of complexity
which you can completely avoid by
getting into a service based business or
an information-based business and i talk
about all the details why in the course
but
there are ideal types of businesses that
you can run
that
create the kind of freedom that most
guys are generally looking for like you
know
most often dudes are like i just want to
be on a beach and you know with my
laptop and make some money okay well i
cover those kinds of businesses and why
they work that effectively and how
location independence is a big big part
of that elf sort of lifestyle that you
want to create for yourself
um so there's a module again on ideal
types of businesses developing a network
look
if you're self-employed and you're going
to run a business and you're going to be
an entrepreneur you need a network you
need to have
guys holding you accountable to certain
standards guys and gals it doesn't
matter i mean i've been a part of
different forums that were either
structured all men or you know
combination of men and women
women do bring value to the table when
it comes to running a business they have
a totally different strategy which is an
interesting component i can talk about
another time maybe i'll save that for
the zoom webinars but
you want to network and i spend time in
that module talking about
how to build a useful network that can
support your goals because
it's it's going to get lonely especially
when you achieve success
before you achieve success people are
going to question you your family is
going to say you're crazy just get a
better paying job you know play it safe
um you know why would you want to expose
yourself that you know that risk that's
never going to work blah blah blah your
friends will do the same thing but what
will eventually happen is all those
people
while they're [ __ ] on you telling
you not to do it trying to you know pull
you back in the bucket you know like
crabs do
at some point when they start to see
your success and you end up you know
like
like
i remember when this hit the front page
of the toronto star
right
that's me okay front frickin page
business section the most popular
newspaper in toronto when my company got
recognized for hyper growth
everybody that used to work for me knew
of me
told me that it was never going to work
to begin with started reaching out to me
for like three days my emails and my
phone were like you know pinging off the
hook
and that will happen right so
you're going to want a network to
support you because
most people are not going to believe in
you or support what you're doing and
you're going to need to build something
around that it's actually one of the
reasons like one of the bonus uh
components of this course that i've
built for you guys and by the way it's
open right now for enrollment the
enrollment closes at the end of the
month okay so on saturday it's gonna
close and then we're going to you know
the students get all the deliverables
we're going to do the monthly zoom calls
and there's some bonuses which i'll talk
about later but
course is open right now
you're going to want the network for the
support when you're in the growth phase
and i talk about you know how to build
that where to go government and
regulations is something that
i never really contemplated when i
started my business i was just like i
got a good idea i'm just gonna go do it
and you know when i was a kid running a
mobile car cleaning business and
delivering newspapers and returning
bottles it's like there's no like the
government and regulators don't bother
you one of the big things that i came
across in my industry with debt
settlement was when i was going down to
the trade shows
down in the u.s and
they were starting to talk about ag's
and if you don't know what the ag is
it's the attorney general for each state
and they're litigious as [ __ ]
and
anytime you get involved in anybody's
life where
things can change for them dramatically
for the better or for the worse if it's
done wrong or if they do things wrong or
they screw it up you know for example
then they're going to point and sputter
at you it's all your fault all this
happened you know because of your
company and there is a huge amount of
activity
especially in the
mid 2000s and uh up until about 2012
2015
with um regulators
coming down on the debt settlement
business and that and that had a whole
downstream you know cascade with a lot
of american companies coming into canada
and i played a big role in the demise of
the canadian market because they ended
up to
over promise and under deliver on what
it is that they were going to do but you
have to understand that government
regulation is going to come your way
anytime you get involved in somebody's
life so
if you sell a nutraceutical like for
example
my entire supplement line i don't make
these supplements okay it's basically
white label like a known company that
has a tested product that meets all the
government regulations and is held to
the standards takes care of the
manufacturing i put my label on it and
it's you know distributed with my logo
and all that sort of stuff so
that's good
that's a better way to do it i've had
friends that like i had a friend that i
met um
at a uh business mastermind event down
in uh cabo st lucas in mexico we were
doing some off-road racing and we spent
a day together in the car and he was
telling me about how he developed this
amazing highly profitable product which
would make skin tags fall off your body
and
pretty much everybody has a skin tag
somewhere they're
they're not moles they're like tags of
skin that like you know come off your
skin for some people it's on like their
body their neck their head you know like
stuff like that and he basically found
natural ingredients that he would put in
a blender blend it up put it in little
packaging with instructions on how to
apply it
and
it was all you know distributed he made
a ton of money it was very effective and
it worked very well until
the attorney general in his state caught
wind of what he was doing
and said that it had to be regulated
because of the ingredients in the
product and they basically suit him into
the stone age because he did it wrong so
you have to understand that if you're
gonna do anything to manipulate
somebody's body
their health
um
you know if you're going to try to
improve it if you're going to you know
sell something that's going to drop skin
tags or whatever
then that's something that government
regulations get involved in same thing
with finance
um you know in the us the government
regulators were coming after companies
that were settling debt
um because of some bad players there's
always a few bad actors in every
industry
and the same thing happened in canada a
few years later when they introduced
bill 55 in ontario parliament and i
lobbied for that bill for about a year
and a half and spent close to 50 60 000
and it ended up being a colossal waste
of time but
i guess in hindsight you know um
that
that's all 2020 is when you have the
perfect vision but
the government will regulate
anything that
and it's and it's kind of funny man i'll
say this as well because
when we were going through the process
the entire point of
what the debt settlement industry was
doing was reducing the debt load to the
consumer so they could pay back a lot
less than what they owed but that was
counter to the profit margins of the
banks and the credit card companies
and you'd think the government
cares about the individual consumer like
the constituents the people that vote
for them that put them in office but the
truth of the matter is what i found out
when i was doing the lobbying is the
government doesn't care about that they
only care about themselves
maintaining their position and
collaborating with the large
institutions banks and credit card
companies and dude i was shocked right
like
so in this module i talk about a lot of
those details i'm not going to bore you
with all that but you know you can get
you can get down in the dirty with that
there's another module on why borrowing
money is generally dumb
um i don't need to spend too much time
on that i think the title pretty much uh
speaks to it but all the details are in
that learning module i talk about human
resources
i talk about why i pivoted from
uh incredible company culture that got
awarded
basically
there's a video on my total debt freedom
channel so if you go search total that
freedom company culture you'll see the
the kind of company culture that i had
in the and the amount of money and
resources i put into
um
that part of the business
uh it's older stuff you know you see me
back in the day with hair and without a
beard and all that sort of stuff but
you can go look that up if you want but
i talk about
human resources versus running yourself
as a company of one
today my preference is company of one
there's a book called company one
there's a big free before you you know
go read it if it's something that you're
interested in but in that module i talk
about the differences between employing
people contractors and doing none of
that and structuring a business in such
a way that it's elf easy lucrative and
fun and that you run yourself as a
company of one
i have one contractor that i pay for
uh customers building audiences and
marketing which is a big part because
you have to figure out well who are you
going to sell to and what right
next module after that is what not to do
in business
because
they don't tell you any of this stuff
you know just like they don't tell you
like
don't be a nice guy to girls you know
be you know be a good man be good at
being a man but being a nice guy to
girls doesn't work you know talked about
that for a few years now so it's the
same thing in business there's a lot of
common misconceptions that
people don't understand when it comes to
running a business and they'll often
make these mistakes which will
contribute to the demise of what it is
that they're running or you know maybe
they end up running it in such a way
that it just isn't profitable isn't
worth it and they're
exposing themselves to too much risk or
dealing with risk you know with employee
issues with
government issues with regulators all
kinds of stuff that can come your way i
talk about all that in that module
pivoting
when bill 55 passed in ontario and we
had to examine i don't know
80 90 pages of legislation that their
lawyers wrote
we needed to find a way to pivot
and that's one thing that you're going
to have to consider as the business
grows
is what you start is not going to be
what you're going to be doing later on
down the road and that's true for all
businesses and
i mean i can tell you right now like
when i started this youtube channel
entrepreneurs and cars
may 23 2014 i'll never forget the day
because it was
part of a
retreat that i did and if you go back
and you start all my videos the very
very first video that i put on the
channels with me and my buddy brad and
we were leaving an entrepreneur's
retreat with a bunch of other guys and i
drove in with him and i drove back with
him
and you know i said him i go you know i
want to do this youtube thing let's put
a gopro on the windshield and let's just
shoot the [ __ ] and see what happens and
the plan at the beginning was
interview
entrepreneurs and their success rides
and tell those stories
that's not what i'm doing today and i've
done a lot of different things over the
years i don't think i'm ever going to
change the name of the channel because i
like the intent of it but
what i'm delivering you know to you guys
today with this course
is basically a mindset course it's gonna
get your head screwed on right so that
you don't make any of the mistakes that
i did or that i've seen others make um
and you know get you to a place that's
gonna
i mean i'm not gonna say it's gonna
guarantee success because that's
entirely you know dependent on your
skill set and what business it is that
you're gonna run but it's certainly
gonna give you the cheat codes to not
making the stupid mistakes that most
guys make so again there's a module on
pivoting
most
in fact all businesses pivot um netflix
pivoted from
uh mailing dvds to streaming services uh
instagram pivoted from a check-in
app to a social media app with pictures
you can go right down the list you can
do a bunch of research on it but again i
talk about pivoting in that module and
it's something that you're going to have
to do if it's not serving you if you're
running a business and it's not serving
you you have to pivot otherwise you will
go out of business and then the last
module is generating business ideas
which is
something that
most guys get stuck on you know in fact
is i want to start a business but i
don't know where to start i need you
know i think i have a good idea but i'm
not sure it's a good idea
that's what i cover in that module so
there's all the course curriculum um
this is just a landing page aka sales
page i break down the problems the cheat
codes the business of course who i am
all the stuff that i've done over the
years the course curriculums there
um you know there's me with a bunch of
pictures of guys here i think uh we've
got kevin o'leary here from an event
that i was at cameron harold which was
my business coach for years this is a
picture of the
staff in my office you know at one point
i've done a bunch of stuff i've done
tours like one of the big things that i
did
over the years as well was
when i was running that business was i
wanted to see examples of other
companies and what they did so i would i
would either drive to or fly to whenever
i was going to an event so
um when i went to this eo university out
in whistler of course you land in
vancouver and my old business coach was
partners with brian scudamore at 100 1
800 got junk and by the way he grew this
business from 2 million in sales to 106
million in sales over six years [ __ ]
phenomenal growth you don't see that
very often so it's like okay well why
wouldn't i when i'm going to this
university head over to 1-800 junk and
hang out with brian for the day that was
um uh
this is one of the other guys in my
forum at the time so you know
like success leaves clues you've got to
go out there and study and i talk about
marketing strategies i've used
everything this is me doing a radio ad
you have to go down in their studio and
they have all the sound boards and stuff
and they record it goes in i've tried
everything you know i've run radio ads
i've done television i've done
pay-per-view clicks fax broadcasting
email marketing i know it works and what
doesn't work um all of this is going to
um you know be talked about in the
module on um marketing right
customers built building audiences and
marketing
building audiences by the way is where
it's at these days but i talk about all
that stuff in in detail
uh i don't know what event this is at i
think this is in vegas when we did
another retreat with another business
forum that i was in and that's i think
that's kevin harrington uh he used to be
one of the original sharks from shark
tank
um
so what's included in the course
is
um there's gonna be
excuse me
let me just take this out of the screen
here um there's going to be um the
course curriculum which which is always
available to you there's going to be um
a private facebook group where you guys
will be able to you know chop up ideas
with each other if there's something
that you want to ask you can tag me in a
post and you know i'll come in and i'll
answer it there's also going to be
monthly zoom calls um which will be held
for the duration of 2022 so the facebook
page just says class of 2022. so
course opens today closes on saturday
you guys will consume the curriculum uh
the private facebook page you'll have
access to immediately the zoom calls
will be updated in the facebook banner
so you'll know when to attend they'll be
recorded if you can't make the time
you want to ask a question again you can
make a post and tag me in it and then
the extra bonus which i didn't put on
this landing page here which i just
established last thursday
i was on my uh call with my business
forum because i run my own business form
it's a red pill business form it's very
similar to eo um those that are watching
that are members of eo it's almost
identical to eo without any of the
wokeness and blue pill [ __ ] so i run
my own forum there's about eight guys in
it
and they volunteered actually to
uh speak during some of the um webinars
so i got a guy that's a uh home builder
in australia home flipper in the us
i got a guy that's a book publisher he's
done
i think well over two or three hundred
titles now
um he does really well he's a young guy
too from sweden um
i got a uh
i'm just gonna call him a hustler from
eastern europe um you know he's got an
interesting way of running his
businesses um i got a guy that runs a
bunch of critical care centers in the us
um you know he's a doctor entrepreneur
so
they're going to chime in as well with
content too to offer some support to you
guys so again you know this is a mindset
course it's designed to get your head
squared away and around what works and
what doesn't work in business
you